easy griddle polenta with delicious
roasty tomatoes and creamy goats curd
now
polenta to the italians is what mashed
potato is to britain's a staple
incredibly delicious and really
straightforward to do now season the
water just a little touch of olive oil
stops it from becoming too sticky
i love polenta it's a cool meal made
from ground dried maize
the more coarse the longer it takes to
cook but you can also buy instant
polenta which is ready in under 10
minutes and always use this at home
and then
whisk that out
as it cooks out
it naturally thickens
you see the grains becoming almost into
one nice fine pureed
polenta
to take the polenta to another level
flavor-wise season with salt and pepper
a good knob of butter and parmesan
quite generous with the parmesan because
polenta can be quite dull i like it
quite rich and creamy
delicious
now
mix that in
a nice smooth shiny glossy planter you
can eat polenta two ways like this it's
a glorious fluffy mash or set then
griddled which is what i'm doing
start by oiling a baking tray pour in
your polenta
now get that in the fridge and let it
set
next i'm roasting fine tomatoes to
really intensify their flavor
olive oil on the bottom of the tray
and drizzle extra virgin olive oil on
top
nip
your tomatoes with your scissors if you
didn't burst them before they went in
the oven they'd explode salt
and pepper garlic
just squeeze the juice out the garlic so
as the tomatoes blister and roast it's
going to take on all this lovely garlic
to give the tomatoes a wonderful sweet
and sour flavor a pinch of sugar and
balsamic vinegar
this is a wonderful aged balsamic
vinegar and then
some thyme
don't pick the time
just trim it like you're having a little
haircut
nice
the tomatoes only take 10 minutes to
roast
now the plant is set it's ready to
griddle
it should just fall out
beautiful plenty of nice garnish for
grilled meats it's great when you're
planning a big dinner party the polenta
can be done one or two days before a
nice season
top and bottom
a nice sort of coating of olive oil and
then onto your grill
now
this looks very impressive but it's so
easy to do
get that grill really nice and hot make
sure you've got a fish slice and go
underneath
to turn
all that nice sort of marking
and char in the blender gives that
really nice flavor
now tomatoes
look
you got these beautiful vine tomatoes
that have been roasted and all that
wonderful flavor
[Music]
now
get your little tomatoes and just sit
them on top
drizzle over any remaining roasting
juices
the perfect addition is a goat's curd
goat's curd gives it that nice sort of
salty
creamy
taste goat's cheese cream cheese or
creme fraiche will work just as well
drizzle
a little touch
of that aged barcelona vinegar and then
a little basil
i can't wait to dive in
this dish is fantastic when entertaining
in the morning set your planter the
night before and you can have this
casual brunch on the table within
minutes fuss-free cooking that looks
like a labor of love first and my
incredibly easy fragrant crispy filo
delicious with a simple honey yogurt now
these are beautiful
fila pastry sheets now it is possible to
make it
but to be honest to try and stretch
the pastry that thin and get it even
it's an absolute nightmare
life's too short to make it at home when
you can buy amazing filo pastry
so
when working with it
always get a nice damp cloth
and just lay
the damp cloth over it that keeps it
nice and moist and it stops
the filler pastry from actually drying
out put a pan on to melt your butter
it's the butter that gives the
crispiness
to the filo pastry
if you're going to brush or coat filler
pastry with butter and make sure that
butter is nicely seasoned
you take
your first
layer lay it onto the board
nice
brush that
with your butter
and the nice thing about filler pastry
is that it can be used for savory
and sweet
these are going to have a fragrant
savoury flavor with thyme black pepper
and parmesan cheese so no need for salt
lift up the corner
and fold very quickly brush the ends
and just
nip
those ends together
non-stick pan on a little splash of
olive oil fry the pastry for one to two
minutes on each side
so you want them to sort of puff up
the secrets get them quickly you can
smell that cheese in that time you're
looking for them to become golden and
crispy simple as that
and then out
smells delicious
and as they sit and cool down
instantly
they become really nice and crispy
the filler goes fantastically well with
thick creamy greek yogurt and a drizzle
of runny honey
there's something quite sort of middle
eastern about the herbs the yogurt and
the honey and the sort of crispy
textures
of the filo pastry an alternative savory
breakfast
when you want a stunning and
sophisticated breakfast that mixes
fragrant herbs and cheese with glorious
honey yogurt this middle eastern treat
hits the spot and it's so simple to make
we're creating bbq style beef brisket
with crunchy coleslaw and sweet potato
wedges which will be right up her street
holly
now
you love barbecues right
so you're gonna help me barbecue this
delicious piece of brisket brisket
look at it
beautiful it's a very tough cut of meat
so it needs to be cooked slowly so it
gets really nice and tender are we
barbecuing it outside we're gonna
actually put the barbecue flavor on
there but we're gonna cook it in the
oven
okay
so mustard powder
okay
here we have some celery seed
next
a little bit of salt in there
okay what's this here cumin two again
nice good now this one
cayenne pepper absolutely right right
two teaspoons of that in there as well
good
now what i want you to do
fresh pepper on there
i'll give that a little mix
roll up your little sleeves and then
i want you
to rub
all that spice
into the brisket
almost like you're massaging it in there
good girl come on holes get your hands
nice and flat on there good girl
now that's nice and coated okay in the
spice
so gas on roasting tray on what we've
got to do now with all those spices is
sear them in a couple of tablespoons of
olive oil into the tray
well done okay good that's getting nice
and hot now you get your brisket
and all that spice
lay that in there nicely
okay so now
we'll start coloring it
as you start to sear in
you smell those spices yep all that
spice left on the plate
we're gonna use yeah
i want you to get the onions
nice and carefully slice them down not
too thin
but just like you're chopping them take
your time
smell all those spices now
good girl
thank you wash my hands i can rub my
eyes
damn holly
was homework that bad no the onions oh
no don't rub your eyes don't rub your
eyes
[Music]
we've got the colour
on the brisket okay yeah
take that out literally for 30 seconds
okay onions into the tray please
nice
you see it's starting to smell slightly
barbecuey already give that a little
stir
nice
now one nice tablespoon of brown sugar
what does the brown sugar do dad so the
brown sugar you're gonna start
caramelizing the onions
right from there my bay leaves in please
good girl oh yes please
right do you want to take over good
careful that tray is very very hot
a tablespoon of tomato puree roast that
off at the bottom of the tray and really
rub it in amongst the onions good girl
now look at the colored onions
right now
time for a little drink
yeah
for the brisket
okay one bottle of earring please so you
go in you put yours in there i'll put
mine here
god uh good health to you and your
brisket good health
bring that to the ball
okay now this is where it gets really
exciting i want you to lift the brisket
up and put it on top of the onions in
she goes
good girl
and then i want to pour the stock all
the way around please
i'm using beef stock but it will work
with chicken stock or even vegetable
stock
once the stock has come to the boil
cover tightly with foil
you just pinch in the ends
flatten that down and then you just
twist
all the way
so that's nice and tight that's the hard
work done thank you
simply pop it in the oven for three and
a half hours and as it cooks you can get
on with the side dishes
first job sweet potato wedges with some
serious flavor
start by making a spice mix in a dry pan
toast coriander seeds until beautifully
aromatic
then put them in a pestle and mortar add
salt and grind
[Music]
next smoked paprika dried oregano
cayenne pepper and mix
spice mix done now simply cut your sweet
potatoes into wedges toss in olive oil
and thoroughly cover with the spice mix
onto a baking tray and into a preheated
oven for 30 minutes turning halfway
it irresistible sweet potato wedgies are
ready now to finish off my beef
see that smell just sort of travels
everywhere
oh ah
now look at that so we can leave that to
rest what does resting mean resting
means where you've cooked a joint and
you just leave it to relax so it'll make
the meat so much more tender okay right
coleslaw traditionally you would mix
slaw with what
mayonnaise that's right mayonnaise this
time
we're gonna do it a little different so
i'd like you to put the yogurt into the
bowl for me
please all of it i'll start slicing the
white cabbage
and the red cabbage now from there a
nice tablespoon
of mustard in there please give that a
nice mix up
nice little touch
of salt and pepper
okay
now
a little cider vinegar so a little
splash of cider vinegar
in there okay as i shred this okay i'd
like you please
then to get the
red cabbage and just open up into that
and mix in at the same time and then you
fold that in there as i start shredding
see how it's coming together yeah
right that's all the red cabbage now the
white
so
you've got that nice vinegary
tartness to the slaw and the yogurt
keeps it nice and fresh
nice little bit in
one more little thing so
put some nice
chopped
fresh chives in there and that will give
it this nice light
onion flavor
so
shines in
[Music]
how's that now taste it with the chives
in there
delicious so
i would like you
to fill up the bowl i'm gonna very
carefully lift out my brisket how come
is it shrunk it's been in the oven
for nearly
three and a half hours
so it's been cooked slowly
that sits on there oh my goodness me let
me just show you what this looks like
i'll start slicing it and see how soft
look at that
and here's the thing about helping daddy
cook
here's the perk
you get to taste it first before anybody
that is so good
that
tastes
delicious
see all that wonderful flavor in there
last job is to create an incredibly
quick and delicious sauce
gas on and reduce the spicy juices and
onions the beef cooked in
then add in cider vinegar and you've got
a brilliant tangy barbecue sauce
that smells nice doesn't it
wow
that is brisket
and a half now the rest of it
can go in the gravy pot
that's a really nice rich
spicy
barbecue
onion gravy
that my daddy
is the perfect way
to serve brisket right you ready
if you carry the sweet potato for me
i've got the brisket wow
let's go donny well done by the way
thank you
this is a real american beauty gorgeous
low and slow cooked barbecue beef
brisket with sweet potato wedges and
yogurt coleslaw